I love you you just make sure you have
to be dreams okay that's ever I love you
we're just outside the door
you're a great hand into the best all
right okay
we invent the wrong mcdonald house as a
last week two years there's so many
different families that come and go here
all the time you're always wondering one
day it's gonna be my time to leave here
but we couldn't do what we do every day
with Katie without being here
that wasn't a was a junior that was
sometime her senior year that was the
summer before the accident
[Music]
Katie was her old soul kid she'd just
soon stay at home be with family watch
20 rounds of Grey's Anatomy Katie's a
type of a kid that trusted to a fault is
nearing the end of her senior year and
she had a lot on her as a lot of seniors
in high school do March 25th 2014
that morning she's been hurt by
something that it happened wouldn't win
a friendship
all I saw was her legs and then got
called my husband I could tell she was
disturbers what she said Rob Katie's
gone I said gone what do you mean gone
and she said she she saw herself one
doctors said that this is probably the
worst wasn't he'd ever seen
they had her over here this morning when
you were on your bike would've been good
Maggie always wanted to get you on your
bike and never did every time she came
through okay here's your spoon
you drive through here we're getting
ready for Katie's face transplant we go
to rehabs during the week and that's
with all these doctors appointments our
weeks are pretty packed money through
Friday say that for me one more time Oh
Katie neurologically she's all there
it's just a matter of sorting through
the files she gets to these episodes
where she found just stops and I mean
don't be sorry Katie
yep right there where your thumb is that
okay the right yep
federal moments where you fall apart
like a house of cards but I think when
you go through something like this to
the best of your ability there's not
much you take for granted anymore Jen
okay okay how do you see things now
we cook something your eyes
even though you have go through all this
it's hard to really describe the
importance of a face but being able to
kiss being able to show emotion those
are basic parts that we take from an
everyday we project to the people in
front of us and then they project back
so you don't get back the feedback that
you only would expect it could be
sadness it could be anger it could be
love it could be affection we've been
very surprised that the remarkable
recovery she's me she's by far not done
and she's a long way to go but in this
case we're talking about someone who has
had the most extensive trauma imaginable
we have to go very far beyond any to do
with conventional techniques or
prosthetics and only a face transplant
can do that
[Music]
we always have a team ready
but once we listed her we came together
as a group it must have been over 50 or
60 here health care givers from every
major area of Medicine that would deal
with her we then did many practice runs
that we continued to do them in the
cadaver lab and as much as we think we
know exactly we want to do every time
something new comes up some other idea
comes up to hopefully enhance what we're
going to do for
since March 18th she's been on the
official face transplant list
every day I you kind of wake up you
think this could be the day and and then
you get through tons where there's not a
call or anything and you kind of get a
little discouraged and disappointed but
with hope and anticipation we know it'll
happen
[Music]
that mean we sleep all night we were
very close like very very far side was
it closer right it was perfect
the problem was oh my goodness I know
the problem was there was some serology
that would have been a no-go for her you
couldn't take the risk so that was it it
will happen next month right now right
now I want one for you too but I want
the right daughter for you okay that's
amazing I wanted to see you hopefully
next time they are very mystical okay we
got that call lets-a-go you need to be
here tonight at 7 o'clock
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we're gonna start with the donor
about seven and I think Katie will pie
get down there by about 9:00 a.m. they
still envisioning 24:32 every time yeah
I imagine I mean I think you know I'm
thinking in my head 30 hours so right
between that timeframe that you're
talking about are you having any second
thoughts
I think you could kind of hear initially
but on the donor we're going to the main
goal is is all is this that's the main
goal this we're gonna do a little bit up
here but it's not a major part of what
what they do thank you universities that
are new every day we thank you for this
opportunity
[Music]
ask doctors down with you
a long way
in order to get to the tissues in the
create space for what we're
transplanting on all this has to be
removed including bone here bone here
bone here bone here and we need access
to it while still preserving things that
make her skull if I Katie there's always
the risk that in the middle of working
to prepare Katie we could have to stop
and be left with virtually nothing
because the donor could become unstable
Katie said to me if something happens to
me during the transplant I don't want
you to be upset I was probably a lot
more nervous than she was
once we make a decision there's no going
back no matter how much planning you do
and we actually got three-dimensional
CTS made of the donor and of Katie to
help us figure this out and despite all
that it didn't matter because in some
ways Katie's face was longer but the
donor space was wider and so we had to
make decisions where are we going to
make it perfect and where as a result
will not be perfect
I kept waiting for them to come out and
say like we've got this problem we got
that this is not what we planned
and was near midnight when we brought
the donor tissues in
[Music]
at that points we have to make a
decision
[Music]
you know the more that we think about
what she would want there lies the
answer not just now but five years ten
years twenty years four years from now
you want to do the gut check again that
gut feeling okay
[Applause]
[Music]
Katie
you know you're out of it
[Music]
[Music]
you look good offense I think we did
everything
she'll be in the hospital for at least a
month but we won't expect any nerve
recovery for probably a minimum of six
months so it's gonna be a long recovery
I would think at least two years before
we see some true stability
the last three months have been they
have been long and had some bumpy days
this charge is like you are
transitioning from one aspect of care to
[Music]
[Laughter]
we did form a lot of relationships with
them because they've watched her for
three years
dr. guessin said the next several months
Katie will be a professional patient
lots of rehab lots of strength training
doctor's appointments
trying to get all her meds settled which
one she'll have to stay on you just know
in your head it's going to be busy
[Applause]
doctor guess and so it would take six
months to a year to get her smile back
the sensation is stronger there
it really is about marching towards
little by little getting back into the
arena of life not back as the way it
used to because nothing will ever be the
same again we're allowed to write a
letter to the donor and their family you
know they would like to receive it then
they can receive it if not they just
keep it at the hospital but we do plan
on writing a letter that's totally up to
them and we totally understand you know
but we're just very grateful
adrià was we didn't always get along you
know how it is with your family but we
didn't being able to spend a time
together in a year or six months before
she passed away
if Adria was willing to donate her
organs you know why would she need a
face you know I still wrestle with that
every knowing that well there's
something I didn't expect and so I
thought about it prayed about it this is
the right thing to do so someone else
can have maybe a better life yeah that's
what made my decision I knew it was
going to take someone special
to give their daughters or
granddaughters their wives face - so
someone else could live need to be
nervous I mean absolutely
I saw the grandma on the drive over
there we can wait outside till it's all
good
just relax and then afterwards we'll go
out for pizza and beer how are you
who is this lovely person hi I'm Sandra
how are you look beautiful I just and
your granddaughter was beautiful
she was a beautiful girl I think that
must have been it was something it was
not long ago really it was a very recent
picture I think you were God for all
that you've done we ask your blessing
upon this
[Music]
you see any change her eye function is
unbelievable I mean close your eyes for
us
I mean smile she couldn't do any of that
a month ago
took home is two years on the other
patients so I'm really excited about
what another month is gonna be for now
you know that's great I mean isn't it
amazing out a way to here and then all
sudden it starts rolling out a little
success after a little success it's been
along but it's been fast
are you sore last night where
oh yeah Booya so we wanted to be sore
sometimes some angles some moments some
daesh's you really appreciate how much
has changed since the transplant what's
the area
whoa
[Music]
for more you feel like it belongs to you
now your new lips
I saw us
[Music]
oh she is today that you right now Rob's
trying to seek employment yeah I'm
begging to teaching for the fall well
that would help us get back into yeah
thank you
if you live long enough you're gonna
walk through something maybe not to this
degree but you're gonna walk through
something and and it's gonna be painful
and you're gonna have very little
control over it but you know you have a
choice to make whether you're going to
hold on to it or use it let it change
you you really have to appreciate life
as a journey and recognize life as a
learning curve having a transplant it's
not you have a transplant you go back to
living it's an exchange it's a different
life and she will always have to
remember I can never not remember to
take my meds but it is an exchange that
won't welcome you got a walk on it yeah
but we have such a long ways to go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you